the Joe Rogan experience do you do any
training on machines or is all your
training essentially done on the road
the running is all pretty much done on
the road and the trails I'll do like
some mobility work and some strength
work in the gym and that's where I'll
I'll kind of go inside I guess for it
but yeah you know I I've used treadmills
and stuff in the past and I do use them
from time to time but usually if I have
the option to go outside I'll do that
and I mean I live in Phoenix so it's uh
you know we're it's sunny Coles day is
seven-day exam there this weekend
actually oh yeah that's right you're at
the is it chimeric America's none
Saturday I'm psyched yeah I love Phoenix
yeah it's the time of year to be there
for sure yeah man right what's what's
the temperature there right now probably
maybe 65 or so I've been there before in
the summer in July when a state MP
improv and it was like [ __ ] 120
uh-huh well and that's that's the funny
thing too cuz when I was training for
that 100 mile 12 hour world record it
was through the summer because the race
was in August so my training was like
110 degrees some days and the funny
thing too is the Petitte Center where I
did the race it was actually built for
speed skating and some hockey rinks so
they keep it at like 60 degrees mmm I
remember one day when I was running it
was like one of the hottest days this
summer I'm are thinking like I'm gonna
race literally at half this temperature
yeah so it's really funny when you when
you see when you see that and I think
I'm I'm no expert at it by any means but
I think there's some pretty cool like
studies and stuff that of the effects
that happen when you are training in
some of those extreme heats like what
happens it for the way was described to
me is it kind of simulates training at
altitude to a degree
hmm so who knows maybe that makes sense
well it's similar to hot yoga right
mm-hmm that's they're doing some studies
at Harvard I believe I think it's
Harvard someone was explaining the whole
deal to me there's not something that I
read but essentially what they're doing
is they're trying to find out whether or
not hot yoga these 90-minute hot yoga
sessions replicates some of the known
benefits of sauna uh-huh because you
know obviously the temperature is not as
hot they keep it the hot yoga place I go
to I think they keep it at 105 degrees
versus sauna you know gets much much
hotter than that you're in like the 180s
which what I like
but the idea is that when your body is
extremely stressed when you're doing
these poses and you're sweating like
crazy that your body core temperature
rises basically to similar level then if
you're just sitting in a sauna so you
get a very similar response yeah yeah
it's it's really interesting so I try to
remember that when it's the summer in
Phoenix so I don't get to miss yeah it's
got you got to be doing yourself good
Kroc Jim which is one of the most famous
boxing gyms in history
Emanuel Steward who was a just a wizard
of boxing and he trained Tommy Hearns
and you know some of the like to
all-time greats of that era he would
crank the temperature and this is in
Detroit they would crank the temperature
up really hot so you'd go into that gym
and it would be that way like for that
specific reason because he believed that
it increased endurance mm-hmm yeah it's
it's interesting stuff but I'll still
take January and February for comfort
now what do you do in terms of like how
do you hydrate yourself and like what
what kind of durations are we talking
about like Savior if it's 110 degrees
outside 120 how it was the hottest you
ran out
I think 110 is what I gotta do and I try
to get out relatively early so that it's
not like 110 from start to finish so
like if I get out say at like 6:00 or
7:00 in the morning you know it might be
in the 80s high 80s and be working its
way up so that like I'm finishing and it
might be 110 for my key workouts the way
I structure my training usually when I'm
kind of in peak is I'll do them my
biggest workout in the morning and then
I might go out and do like a second run
that's like a little shorter or quite a
bit shorter in most cases and really low
intensity and you know then sometimes if
it's the afternoon in Phoenix that's
when I would see like that 110 but I'm
usually not out for more than like 45 60
minutes for those so hydrating is is
interesting because you know I grew up
in the Midwest so I was very familiar
with running in hot humid stuff in the
summer and you know the dry desert heat
though it seems like you get thirsty a
lot quicker and a lot more frequently so
I you know one of the things I learned
the first summer I was in Phoenix was
knowing where the water fountains are
and kind of planning our heads around
that you drink out of public water
fountain
why don't have to you worry about
cooties I haven't gotten anything to
miserable yeah in fact I did a race
earlier this year it was in early June
called the San Diego hundred and it's
got this spot in the middle of the
course where the aid stations are a
little further apart there's like a nine
mile stretch in a seven mile stretch and
I kind of missed timed how much water I
did so I filled up my water and a stream
and it was probably not an ideal Oh food
but I rolled the dice and it just don't
get known get anything Pat no I've my
thought during the race was this is the
mindset in the middle one of these
things is like well if something really
bad happens will happen after the race
so hope definitely would but it's really
bad yeah already is rough I've never had
it but the people that I know that have
had it say it's really bad but you know
you could just bring a SteriPEN yeah but
you can't really stop huh yeah I mean
yeah in a race I wouldn't want to yeah
and what what really helped for me was
the the situation is since the track
rate since the race was on an indoor
track 400 and like I think 42 and some
odd meters I was doing a lot of my big
long runs on a 400 meter track okay so
when I did that I would just bring out
like a cooler I don't have ice and water
in there I would sit there waiting for
you oh that's sweet yeah that makes
sense but when you do a lot of trail
running though right I do some of that
too yeah historically I've done a lot
more flat runnable stuff but now that
I'm out in Phoenix I like to try to
split the year into two halves and do
some trail stuff in half the year and
some like flat or rogue or track or
runnable stuff in the second half do you
bring water when you run trails do you
bring like a backpack or something like
that like one of those um you know what
Zach yeah yeah with the tubes yeah but
the [ __ ] is that camels camel camel
backs
yeah there's I'll do I don't usually use
what they call like the bladder which is
the tube thing that you're talking nice
though they are and you can pack a lot
of water um usually unless I unless I'm
gonna be away from a potential stop long
enough usually what I'll do is I'll I'll
use the pack but I'll have like small or
a little like like little flasks soft
flax in there okay so you bring those to
that even like on the the chest straps
yeah and a lot of people with those but
you're rolling the dice with that like
you got to know how much does sip yeah
you know we're we're lady the pickup
spots are for more
run with friends yeah when I run with my
dog in the summer when it gets really
hot I bring a hydro flask in a backpack
and I'm one of those collapsible dog
bowls cuz you know I don't want him
drinking out of puddles and jacket and
so but that just having that extra
couple pounds on your back it makes a
difference you can you feel it yeah
yeah and that's that's why part of the
reason why I try to go as minimal as I
can with water if I if I can get away
with it obviously if I go out and do
like a big loop where there's no
potential stops I'm gonna have to carry
it all from the beginning but if it's a
spot where I know like I can get to
water every five six seven miles then
usual I'll pack a little lighter and not
be carrying as much at any one given
time do you hydrate up before you go
yeah I mean I think it's the ones one of
the hardest things to really get right
in Phoenix was just like kind of
learning kind of how much you need to be
hydrating like between sessions cuz what
I usually found out is I could go out
and kind of neglect hydration for anyone
given like run or workout but if I did
that then the next one I'd probably pay
for it so for me the big motivation to
make sure I'm on top of hydration during
any given run is because I know like if
I don't then the next one is gonna
potentially be I've done that before
that's that's a weird feeling trying to
do anything when you're dehydrated it's
like you have a bad battery or something
yeah it's like everything's like oh come
on it's it's it's amazing how just
normal everyday life like you could feel
like a little run down and you barely
notice it but once you start physically
exerting once you start training once
you start doing something hard that's
when you become like really in tune with
how you're screwing your body up like
drinking for instance mm-hmm like have a
couple of drinks and then run like oh
god you're like well this is what it's
doing to my body yeah I gotta [ __ ]
stop drinking you know yeah yeah I think
you you I like drinking to thirst that's
usually what my gauges and I haven't
really had any issues with its with that
with that so there's no like strategy
like say I'm gonna run 25 miles today
let me drink X amount of liters of water
before I go out no before the run ya
know I try not to like do too much like
kind of like
preemptive hydrating because I think
what you want what people oftentimes I
think do then is they drink too much and
then that comes out at the expense of
your electrolytes too because your
body's going to screech those so if I'm
if I find myself
could you just supplement you can't yeah
and I'll do a lot more of that
especially in the heat too just in
general is like having a like
electrolyte supplementation and things
like what do you use for your
electrolytes supplementation I use a
product called hydro ax mostly it's a
like a powder that you can kind of mix
in with your water by a company name X
endurance they have they make these
little tubes now to wear like so if I'm
running and I have like one bottle with
some in it already
I can have these little like just these
little tubes that if I've refill and
want to put more and I can just kind of
take them all pop it off and and pour
that in but a lot of other people will
use do you can make like little caps
that you just like swallow it with your
water and it's got like the formulation
of the different electrolytes in there
kind of dialed in and you know that's a
I think that's a little more hit or miss
as to like like where people feel you
need that some people tell you don't
really need look-alikes at all you just
need to salt your foods and things like
that all the weight so like you should
be taking X number of these every hour
there's got to be science behind it
right I mean do you are you getting
blood tests and finding out what your
levels are pre and post workouts or
anything along those lines yeah I
haven't done any like post workout tests
to say other than I know I was part of
the faster study which was a study that
looked at high carb and high fat
athletes and I think they were looking
at some of that stuff too and like
anytime I've ever had a blood test done
though by like my my electrolytes like
my sodium potassium levels always been
in range so I haven't really tried to
it's one of those things then where it's
like I'm probably not gonna try to fix
something that's not broken
[Applause]